there are some parts of history which we
are drawn to we have a soft spot for
them and for me those are the dark ages
well later this year Assassin's Creed
are going back there two letters live
out our raiding fantasies and live as a
Viking
[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
today we are talking about Assassin's
Creed Valhalla breaking down what you've
missed in the trailer so far and also
some things revealed only in interviews
I've teamed up with Ubisoft to tell you
14 things you should know about the
Viking Age and Assassin's Creed Valhalla
and as this is a sponsored video there's
a link in the description if you want to
know more about the game and the
pre-order editions like a wolf I kid you
not there is a wolf
we'll get to that very soon let's set
the scene here's a quick history lesson
around 1000 AD
long before Thor was a Marvel superhero
the Norse people set up raiding groups
tasked with traveling around coastal
Europe raiding settlements in order to
take goods and there may have been a
little bloodshed - history tells us the
first time the Viking longboats arrived
in England the villages there came to
greet them and were all massacred the
Vikings didn't mess around shall we say
they were renowned for their military
might and also their advanced sailing
skills this show of force led to a time
period known as the Viking Age of
invasion as the North Men widened their
empire one such country targeted was
England who at that exact moment in time
were being torn apart by warring kings
the country was completely broken into
factions hey it was definitely called
the Dark Ages for a reason so much
bloodshed and deceit in Assassin's Creed
Valhalla
we play as one of those Viking warriors
looking to set up home inside England by
any means necessary but this story isn't
as black and white as you may think we
will definitely be cutting down
thousands of combatants but a large
portion of the game is all about our
settlement every swing of our ax ax gets
us one step closer to growing the
community of our dreams we will take on
missions to help our town prosper the
settlement is so important to the
gameplay that it's our hub for accessing
missions and will change throughout the
story the settlement grows new people
arrive with professions like a
blacksmith and even a barracks will
eventually pop up Assassin's Creed
Valhalla attempts to include a dynamic
community system in what's your
decisions in mission
have a knock-on impact on your hometown
it's it's actually possible for weddings
to happen so that's the return of
romances confirmed but these marriages
have political impact too marrying into
another tribe creates an alliance a sort
of stability and just in case you
thought this was a one-way street
the flip side of that can happen two
relationships break down and brother
fights brother the alliances aren't just
between Vikings either it's possible for
Ava to form relationships with the kings
of the land cuz back then in England
there were four kings at this point it
was difficult to keep up so ultimately
don't be surprised when one day you
arrive home and see your entire
settlement up in flames because that's
how all marriages end right as the game
progresses the decisions we make become
harder and Avon must decide if his own
personal priorities outweigh the greater
community goal and the fallout from each
of those decisions is said to be tough
but we'll have to wait for more
information so I've mentioned Dave or
the badass Viking we control well if
your first reaction was a was a girl's
name then technically you're right
because in Assassin's Creed Valhalla we
choose to play a var as either a man or
woman and the biggest thing to note is
whoever you choose is right for the
cannon story their name will go down in
history both trailers so far have
completely focused on male AVO which is
likely the Viking we all see in our
minds before the reveal female a var is
a round though have found her in a few
images and let's be honest if you are
able to choose right this moment would
you choose to play as male or female Ava
hmm tough choice isn't it I think I'll
make a poll it'll probably on screen
right now I'll be honest I'll be
choosing female Ava because we all know
that girl stands for guy in real life
it's true another huge part of this and
many Assassin's Creed games is the
ability to customize our characters and
Valhalla takes this further than ever
before we can choose to have a beard I
presume that's just the male Ava we can
select our water paint we can choose our
tattoos expect to see me running around
with a butterfly [ __ ] stamp
the usual clothing options and armor
changes are here too and it looks like
male Ava could even run around sure
plus to show off those tats on by the
way the tattoo parlor is yet another
upgrade for our settlement overall the
customization is deep even your long
boat can be customized and your raiding
party too
Oh in fact let's break those down now as
you'd expect Viking longboats will be in
this game and are a key aspect of
gameplay but not as many people would be
expecting due to how great naval battles
were in previous ACC games you may
expect cannon battles but simply put
that was not the Viking style their long
bolts were defensive outlets designed
for fast approaches and even quicker
retreats and that's how they'll play in
Valhalla
we will set up raid parties with NPC's
in the game selecting and customizing
their appearance and weaponry and then
man the longboats to find a Battlement
to attack outer nowhere we simply jump
out start the absolute barbaric mayhem
and then jump back into our longboat
to get away if needs be these will be
occasional main missions but more often
they will be additional objectives and
at the time was used to gain materials
to upgrade boats and settlements or to
trade with other tribes to keep the
peace basically any military location
you find is fully Raider Bowl in
Assassin's Creed Valhalla and dude
there's a battering ram tooth so count
me in I'm sure I don't need to tell you
this most of the gameplay loop in
Assassin's Creed Valhalla is about
fighting I know it's shocking isn't it
well a little more than that something
you should know is about the dual
wielding system in which both arms are
treated as separate entities and can be
used to hold two separate weapons in
battle so far we've seen the coolest
duel axes I've ever seen in a video game
but there's also knives swords bows
spears and shields and here's a big one
it's been confirmed it's possible to
dual wield shields that's hard to say by
the way captain Viking America confirmed
and just in case you were wondering the
hidden blade is sure here beautifully
utilized in the first trailer but have
you noticed it isn't under the wrist
anymore it goes without saying the
hidden blade doesn't belong on top of
the arm but then you've got to admit
punching an Englishman in the face would
be so satisfying with that on
I'm English I didn't mean that please
don't punch me if you see me in the
street I did a little digging and it
looks like a vote meets an assassin who
gives him the weapon but Ava doesn't
have a clue what an assassin is and also
doesn't understand how a hidden blade
works so therefore he straps it on the
top of his arm which looks so badass
so far I've seen three different hidden
blades on Ava suggesting either they
upgrade as the story continues or
alternatively they are customizable just
like pretty much 90% of the things in
this game any game with a Viking in is
instantly going to make us all think
about Norse mythology God of War was the
most recent game to go there and now
we're all expecting Odin and Thor to pop
up in every game that has a Viking in it
so far we've actually seen flashes of
Odin and both his and Thor's totems have
been seen set up too when asked about
how deep the game will go into religion
and mythology the devs confirmed it will
indeed be there but it won't be as
fantasy based as other games and instead
is a little more realistic I'm not sure
what to make of that
I guess Thor won't be joining us in
battle just yet saying that we have
actually seen holding on the battlefield
in what looks like an assassin's cloak
but I can't back that up in the
slightest so let's move on
oh the eagle-eyed of you see what I did
there may have noticed Odin's Ravens
whether these are his Birds let me just
find out what they're called okay they
called Hugin immunes I apologize for
that pronunciation or whether this raven
is just a similar-looking raven either
way it's quite pivotal to how you play
those who have played the last few
installments of Assassin's Creed will
already know the use of the bird but if
you don't it's quickly used to get a
bird's-eye view of the world below in
Valhalla wherever you go a black raven
will come with you for exploration I try
to get more information but Ubisoft are
staying tight-lipped on what that bird
can do they have said there is a bunch
of new abilities but we'll just have to
wait and see what they are hold on
there's another area which breaks
realism as you'd expect will primarily
be using horses to travel around on land
but did you see what the ultimate
edition of the game has with it it has a
wolf mount as a pre-order bonus
Assassin's Creed have done this in the
past
I remember a unicorn like Pegasus beast
I'm sure I've seen a ball too well now
in Valhalla there's a Haiti wolf mount
like back in the days of World of
Warcraft Leroy Jenkins would be proud
Ubisoft sent out some text documents and
fact sheets and one of those tells us
about minigames in Valhalla to lighten
the mood you know the kind of thing
which takes your mind off pillaging for
a while we know they'll be gambling
which involves some sort of dice and
drinking games like a true drunken
Viking but the best thing you'll hear
today are these words Viking rap battles
confirmed no word of a lie to add
context to that I don't think the
Vikings with Attitude Era is going to
take off it's more of an insult battle
two guys would be surrounded by their
community at a drinking establishment of
their choice and they would take it in
turns to offend the other person the
crowd reaction would dictate the winner
and that person will be filled with
drinks for the rest of the evening who
said these videos weren't educational
you can impress your friends with an old
English word flighting but I prefer rap
battles let's get all the housekeeping
out of the way Assassin's Creed Valhalla
is scheduled to release holiday 2020 and
releases on the PS 5 the ps4 the Xbox
one the Xbox series X the PC and stadia
- ok that sentence almost broke me if
you're wondering why people assume it's
solely on Xbox it's just one of those
things publishers and platforms
regularly align themselves to maximize
their reach
don't you dare worry pretty much play
Assassin's Creed Valhalla wherever you
game in terms of editions now or how
there's many to choose from
as always with Ubisoft games the base
game gets you exactly that the core
experience without any bells and
whistles the gold edition includes a
bonus mission and the season pass which
confirms the game will be supported and
updated for a long time which is good to
know isn't it and then there's the
Ultimate Edition which has all of that
plus lots of in-game items including
that wolf mount we talked about and
there's totems and a tree for your
settlement and tons of customization
options - like weaponry and long boat
items and there's even rooms to carve
into your favorite weapons and finally
the collector's edition which has so
much stuff I don't know where to start
and to be honest if I start looking at
this I will buy it again and my
girlfriend will complain about it she
doesn't understand
how important it is to have a 30
centimeter Viking on your desk there are
so many more things I wanted to talk
about but I think that's enough for one
video let me know if you'd like me to
cover this in more depth in future I
really would love to but that's all on
you you guys dictate this channel I'm
Adam from PlayStation granade it's been
a pleasure see you next time
[Music]